من غزه وائل ما المعلومات المتوفره لديكم
حتى الان الحديث يدور عن اطلاق صاروخ واحد
على الاقل او صاروخين انطلاقا من قطاع غزه
لكن كما جرت العاده لا يوجد اي بيانات
صدرت عن اي جهه من الفصائل الفلسطينيه هنا
في قطاع غزه ولا من غرفه العمليات
المشتركه ولا حتى من الدوائر الرسميه او
الجهات الرسميه هنا في القطاع تبلغ عن
وجود حوادث
وبالتالي ظل الامر مقتصرا على شهود العيان
الذين قالوا بانهم سمعوا اصوات انفجارات
وكانت هذه الانفجارات مصحوبه همم شهب في
السماء ويبدو انها ناجمه عن اطلاق القبه
الحديديه الاسرائيليه في محاوله لاعتراض
همم هذان الصاروخان واا بالتالي هذه
المعلومات المتوفره حتى الان لكن كان
واضحا بان الاوضاع ربما تتوتر عقب عمليه
اغتيال القياده في الجهاد الاسلامي فاروق
سلامه في جنين وكانت الجهاد الاسلامي قد
اصدرت ايه بيان همم عقب عمليه الاغتيال
قالت بان هذه العمليه سوف تفتح ابواب
الجحيم على اا قاده الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وفق ما جاء في البيان وقالت بان العمليه
لن تكسر اراده كتيبه جنين وانها سوف تستمر
في المقاومه وهو وهي الجمله ربما
والعبارات التي
اشارت بان الجهاد الاسلامي يمكن ان ياتي
الرد من خارج قطاع غزه لكن كما يبدو اا
يعني هذا اطلاق هذه الصواريخ على الاقل
حتى الان تبعا لشهود عيال واضح بانه يمكن
ان يتبعه همم رد من جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي او ضربات في قطاع غزه